One of the things that is so
amazing about this show
is how formidable the actors are.
And one of the true
highlights of the season
is the scene
where you have
Reese and Marcia Gay Harden.
You're the truth teller.
Was that true?
Being in any scene with
Marcia Gay Harden
you have to stay on
your toes, because she will
pivot and turn on you and
you better be prepared!
It's so fun to have
her as a scene partner.
I think that people change.
I think people grow.
I know I'm evolving,
I wonder if you are.
I love that Bradley gets to say
that I think we have
to make room for
people to change and grow.
Watching these two titans
face off and have
this conversation.
Do you have to cancel Alex?
Is that what we're here to do?
Or is there an opportunity
for forgiveness?
It's at the root of what a lot
of people are thinking right now,
but not very many
people are saying.
You're not going to Mitch
Kessler's memorial are you?
I am.
With Yanko
I had to come up with
sort of a backstory as to
why does he feel the need
to go to the service
knowing what this man has done?
I think he's probably there for
Mitch's kids to say,
I knew your dad a long time
and I think on a moral level he
needs to do that for himself.
My youngest asked me
if all of dad's friends
would be there?
I think these characters
have a choice to make -
really asking themselves
when our heroes
end up being more villainous.
Then we thought, well how am I
gonna respond to this?
And I think true to life
some people decide
that I'm going to
respond to the man that I know
the man that was in front of me.
I wasn't gonna come but I
just kept feeling that I had to
and to say a few words about
Mitch and what he meant to me.
For Alex, she sacrifices
her legacy in a way
by going to the funeral
and speaking the truth.
I think it's the beginning
of a big shift for her.
I'm gonna be cancelled,
Cory, for things that I did.
Alex I think feels
pretty much at the bottom
of the barrel as a human being.
The loss of her only friend,
soulmate on the planet.
Her hypocrisy within herself,
what she asked him to do --
the guilt of that.
It's like that thread
in a sweater
that's just getting
pulled and it's just gonna
unravel and unravel and unravel
until she finally
just kind of...
You'll see.